[Music]
every look is an exotic food a paramour
less Portia un Camino for young woodworm
is macaca California
it means Serrano's load nonporous Trico
the sorrowful I use the window acaba 0bo
Ventura I'm a capella food eaters Anubis
one since birth after you hang up wife
of Hawaii support from staff defers
about how I'm something you pretty
people
Tammy locust mark Akita Pilates our
salmon groups are only here in the
barangay fme luckily Pama papinek ahoy
periodic Epirus in lhasa away a young
Tami look we determine determine my
Heera Panna P hersheimmer IVD to suffer
garbage damage wouldn't reveal of any
Baba for thus ago but gonna keep in
Makiki tomandamanda hospitals Attica to
mogul o un punto de un me caribbean
bella mignon under PA you can
automatically young Camilla for Mohammed
in a silicone testa me look for during
serving a young citizen column gender
issue ellonija pardon young kina Enya
Topanga do you mean I anime theme boughs
elegant Puna world young silly hat silly
my own
well I'm getting too big young saucer a
me look who is up around Ulster support
then parent makin thing amis human
Alessandro for you you can end up winner
would a young Camilla for is actually
but unknown she's in the whole world
Varanasi apparent psychic am can be low
morale by syrup novusera
[Music]
[Music]
on the Italian island of Sardinia there
is a delicacy that has been consumed for
thousands of years it is known as the
world's most dangerous cheese yeah you
heard right
[Music]
meet Simona IVA a third-generation sheep
farmer demo chief the change in quantity
to pay current approval changmo last
question a party questo lot a little
easy on welfare Adel formaggio kazuma's
Kazu marzu literally means rotten cheese
and it's not for the faint of heart
because this cheese is infested with
thousands of live maggots and while that
might seem a bit off-putting at first
it's the maggots that give the cheese
its distinctive texture and flavor
here's how it works first a traditional
wheel of pecorino cheese is made from
sheep's milk then a special fly called a
cheese fly is allowed to lay its eggs in
it la forma Sara complimenting bizarre
de las calles isla del sol Darwin over
the course of two three months the
maggots eat the cheese and then excreted
out again transforming it into the soft
and creamy
Kazu Marzu / support began in Sephora
diverse gusto pastuzo la voce fala
monster today it's a favorite for
special occasions like weddings and
birthday parties but eating this cheese
can be dangerous second local Kunal's
vehicle team of evil intent
Nanako z say no sorry mo PA de vere me
not but can imagine de la vita even
though cases like this are extremely
rare it's risky enough that the cheese
is illegal to sell but farmers like
Simona continue to make it for
themselves don't poke aquila get fun on
college for money much but all law
simply kamasutra
your non lucano suit mean only in the AG
and they just can't get enough for much
a match for pursuit on a fitting ID
Milan
la morte soon
it was a trial that captivated a nation
lorena bobbitt lorena bobbitt lorena
bobbitt took a knife cut off her
husband's penis but what does lorena
bobbitt have to do with this thing let's
take a step back this is the bobbitt
worm it's a species of eunice union
Unite see thanks Terry you're most
welcome
let's dr. Terry Gosselin er ter ry g
he's a senior curator at the California
Academy of Sciences and I do research on
coral reefs around the world he's the
one who gave the bobbitt war of its name
they go way back
in 1992 I went to the Philippines and I
saw my first Bobbitt work to actually
see it in action was really one of the
most amazing things I've seen this thing
has nope nope nope written all over it
I'm sorry what from it spiked glowing
exoskeleton and the body is very
iridescent shiny - its spring-loaded
jaws they just spring shut like a bear
trap and its unique predatory style when
it sees a fish it pops more and more out
of the water and then grabs the fish and
takes it back into the sample what
anyway after years of research in the
indo-pacific dr. garner published this
book coral reef animals of the Indo
Pacific when it came time to name the
worm dr. Gosselaar found an unlikely
source of inspiration there was this guy
named John Wayne Bobbitt who had cheated
on his wife and while he was sleeping
one night she cut off his penis and
threw it in a field nearby wait what and
in the worm basically the the ability to
use as massive jaws to cut the spinal
cord of a fish was something that
reminded me of what Lorena Bobbitt did
to her husband so there you have it
something else give you everything
[Music]
a hundred and fifty feet underground and
thirty million year old caves an
unforgettable sight glitters in the dark
the Waitomo glowworm caves in New
Zealand are home to about 30,000 endemic
Iraq no Campa lumen OSA glowworms
they spend their days spinning silk
nests from the ceilings
and then lowering threads to fish for
prey much like a spider the luminescent
bead like strings are spellbinding the
glow worms use light to attract prey and
burn off waste the glow is created by a
combination of chemicals given off by
the glow worm and the oxygen in the air
the caves are ideal for the worms as
they need a dark damp location where
their light can be seen the waitomo
caves they call home are named after the
Maori words way which means water and
Tomo which means hole or shaft and
although they live deep underground the
journey to see them is never one to
disappoint in Lama Sonia tenemos two
universes roducts por ejemplo L chant
ocurro productos que cualquier
restaurant de tresses trade mission inna
interlock cierra tener es un de ver el
que tengo el de poder mostrar esta
cocina
you think all oportunidad everyday de
contar al mundo colada
[Music]
mi nombre es confuse any Seto
so um cocinero especially southern
cocina Masonic yo Chrissy dentro la
cocina de una cocina Francesa guna
cocina americana una docena traditional
Equatoria 'no pero nunca me hablar on de
la cocina Mazzoni de todas cuando vengo
a beer ALP weed okay medo de cuenta de
que hay una nueva Cocinita Cunha cocina
des conocida para ESO me - Veera Selva
dentro para poder entender en realidad
que es la cocina Masonic Oh siempre que
un producto nuevo que una persona quiere
lova probar por primera vez siempre hay
una resistencia a a low des conocido le
damos a pro bar enchant occur okay del
gusano de llamas o'neill lo venko como
me a trave oh no Meah Trevo pero el
momento que se a traving hasta ahora no
ella Grado no hemos encontrado una
persona que nos diga que canta occur
okay Lozano les aparecido FeO
[Music]
Enchantix eurozone a las cámaras
emblematic Iselle Amazonia dellacroix
doe aparte de Gisela Tribune a
propiedades Curitiba's contra la gripa
calm problema respiratory owes to DeLeon
Takuro es algo que puede tener una / en
sia algo diferente pero que el sabor es
muy bueno y sobre todo la port a
nutritional que le hacia la persona a
MIA for toda demente en todo el
recorrido kamo Sechin Amazonia nada
dejado de gustar me todo para Maya's yo
Rico yo vivo con ven sido de que la
cocina amazonica tiene que tener el
mismo respeto que el resto de las
casillas son productos nutria TiVo's y
que trabajar con una buena technique a
culinary op Weyden estar en cualquier
cocina sin quest race